so you been Bron rich on Ohio State Sam
no I think the University of Michigan is
a fantastic school okay Ann Arbor is a
wonderful town thank you
the state of Michigan is a great state
just great lakes great times they'd
never have gotten rid of that slogan and
if I was an Oklahoma fan I would be
irritated beyond belief that Ohio State
was ranked ahead of them okay see what
I'm saying that now that's that right
there is is normal but your your out of
the ordinary when it comes to people
that called hashtag titi UN you know
what I mean sadly I feel you're correct
okay Bryan win horst the very
level-headed Bryan win Horst here on
Rich Eisen show where's Eric Bledsoe
going brother what do you think well
there's a couple of teams that have
offers into in for him but you know they
say you see situations like this happen
over the summer where you get a
stalemate between a player and a team
and basically what you're waiting for is
some event to happen out there to make
somebody desperate because the sun's
asking price for him which is either a
really good draft pick or a good young
player on his rookie contract
nobody's offering that right now because
the suns are leveraged if you're talking
with the Suns you're saying listen this
guy's had multiple knee issues and
you've defamed him you've called him a
liar and a bad guy in public so why
should I pay good money for you or you
got money but you know good value for
him and so what's probably gonna happen
here is is there's gonna take an event
either there's something to happen for
the sons to move on or something to
happen to another team out there an
injury or something else that we can't
see the future on that causes people to
change their position otherwise I think
we're gonna have the stalemate continued
hmm so you think he Thanksgiving he's
still sitting there in Phoenix right
because I can't like you know for
example the Milwaukee Bucks have an
offer in okay for him the you know the
Bucks want to offer something like
Matthew Dellavedova and their
first-round pick this year which won't
be that good
well the the when the son call they say
when we wants on maker we want you know
a young guy in the you know who's got a
potential to be a really good player and
they really have nowhere to go
that they have our position you have
your position so if you say to me well
what happens if the Bucks suffer an
injury in their backcourt between now
and Thanksgiving what that change things
yes but what if that injury doesn't
happen what if it happens to another
team whatever doesn't happen until
December
I mean honestly is a really good
question by you but I am in the position
where I can look at the lay of the land
and say something is gonna have to
happen but we don't know when that
events going to take place and that's
why the Sun because frankly rich the
Suns aren't trying to win right now
they're just fine with losing so they'll
just sit there and wait it's not
incumbent on them their owner has
obviously made it clear he doesn't care
about paying eric bledsoe eighty
thousand dollars a day which is what
they're paying him not to play for him
so we'll just keep going could be
Thanksgiving could be Christmas my guess
would be December 15th and the reason
rich is December 15th because when all
the guys who signed last year become
available to be traded that's about 30
percent of the league so in December
15th area I would think it will be done
by then as long as something doesn't
happen between now and then that causes
more urgency ESPN's Brian Winn Horst
here in the DirecTV NBA 4k report here
on the Rich Eisen show okay after the
Knicks blew out Cleveland in Cleveland
for easily the the high-water mark of
the porzingis era in new york right now
tyronn lue said after the game until we
get our spirits right it's going to be
like this what does he mean by spirits
Brian yeah when you what if you watched
that game I said on television yesterday
that they played has asked but actually
I think I was wrong I think they played
quarter after they gave no you know
what's about that game and you could
read it all over their body language and
you know to me you know they have some
they have some issues that are
interesting you know how does Derrick
Rose and Dwyane Wade two guys
don't shoot three-pointers mesh with an
entire roster designed to shoot
three-pointers how do their D out of
their defensive challenges Maps s
themselves long-term but at talking
about X's and O's right now with the
Cavs was kind of moot because they're so
not interested in competing and you know
there could be a bunch of reasons why
excuse me you have the fact we're coming
off three finals you have the fact that
they have the oldest team in the NBA and
this is the earliest start to a season
that's ever happened and yeah the fact
that they don't have you know real tough
challenges in the Eastern Conference so
do you think that the answer could be
Isaiah Thomas that he could give they a
shot in the arm and a boost of energy
and you know his infectiousness like
that's what's missing even though he
hasn't been part of his team well it's
not fair to evaluate them until he comes
back because when you watch them right
now what you see is a team that is just
a suspect on defense as they were last
year but doesn't have the same offensive
firepower so their margin for error is
smaller but you know when Isaiah comes
back they're gonna get a giant weapon
back so I think the most interesting
thing about the Cavs right now is it
tyronn lue is saying this is
unacceptable we've got to play better
you know we can't afford these types of
performances and you have LeBron James
saying that's no big deal other than
that I'm not too worried about him but
it's interesting that LeBron and tyloo
are taking such opposite ends of the
spectrum because last year they were a
bad defensive team all year long and so
the concept is maybe start playing
defense little earlier so it becomes a
habit
that's what ty lue is trying to do and
the Cavs you know haven't been
reciprocating yet last one for year
Brian WA Norris DirecTV for K NBA report
because you know obviously there's so
much time between now and the end of the
season so you tell me when is it
acceptable or when is it reasonable how
about that word when is it reasonable to
start talking about LeBrons thinking for
his future
during this season when is that what
give me a date certain that you think
it's reasonable to start talking about
that if we unless we've already reached
that point well your the thing is LeBron
and the team's live in two different
worlds the teams that want to sign
LeBron have to think about it a year in
advance so if you're a fan of the Lakers
are your fans of 76ers or and you know
something like that
and you have a dream you can talk about
it now but when it comes to LeBron it's
kind of like you know rich when does the
when does the team plane leaves the team
plane leaves when LeBron is ready for it
to leave okay LeBron goes on his
schedule and so he knows that whenever
he says where he wants to go it will
happen so as much as people because
their teams have to prepare for so long
as much as they want and they so badly
want this because I go around the
country and and that the thirst is so
strong LeBron doesn't have to worry
about it until December I told you until
June because you know just like the team
plane it leaves when he would he wanted
to leave Brian appreciate the time it's
the first of many really appreciate the
call all good man a lozenge and take two
and call me in the morning
that's Brian with a twin worst ESPN for
more Rich Eisen show tuned - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Rich Eisen show app